blue face baby yeah all right check me
out on the dj head podcast oh you said
dj head [ __ ] bootleg cavs oh
[ __ ] your head is my old coach blue face
baby yeah all right
i'm on a podcast with dj
it's bullet kev
damn what
bootleg kev
yes
[Laughter]
blue face baby here all right i'm here
now he now he's scolding me bro
all right come on dude blue face baby
yeah all right come check out the
podcast with bootleg care man it's about
oh
yo bootleg head podcast
bootleg kev show special guest my guy i
ain't seen you in a minute bro man blue
face baby blue face is in the building
bro yeah hey first of all the rings are
crazy is this the are these the newest
pieces
nah these are old
in fact the last time i saw you
i don't even remember when it was but i
remember you had the uh the bandana oh
yeah i still got that that should look
very uncomfortable to wear on a daily
basis it definitely is like a neck brace
but you know
you know it's just a look
how's everything going man this new
record with blast is [ __ ] crazy chose
me
you know about that man
i feel like this right i was telling
whack i was like yo this is gonna be the
easiest record job i've had to work to
radio since
this [ __ ] is a layup classic a layup
classic yeah how's um
i feel like i've been seeing you a lot
obviously for for
for controversial reasons yeah online
you know i'm just
just
i don't even know what to say i don't
know
you know just it just happens it just
happens right
i don't i don't even try
to do it i'm not you know just
i don't know
talk to me um
you know during the pandemic you opened
a restaurant yeah yeah blue spaces so i
feel like you've been um
very active as far as just like leveling
up on some entrepreneurial [ __ ] during
the pandemic like
you know what the pandemic actually did
that for me
because the [ __ ] got slow and i'm like
[ __ ] what i'm gonna do
so i started this only fan show as well
called blue girls club oh yes you did
yeah yes i did
listen i haven't subscribed are you on
there [ __ ]
you got to subscribe listen i don't want
to see mine i know you so i don't want
to see your dick
it's my version of blue girls club so
basically what i do bad girls club oh
yeah bad girls club yeah your version of
that yeah yeah so basically what i do is
i
pick like 15 women from instagram all in
different states from the united states
different cities and i fly them all out
and i move them into my house and their
incentive
to come is just to be with you or you
know it's the the platform
you know so you're not paying these
women no no they just get the they get
you know you get to come stay here you
get some exposure yeah you get the
exposure you get to stay here
everything's free like we
dick
no
so you're not [ __ ] any other women oh
man
it's not a dating show it's not blue
girls i'm just hosting
so i'm the type of person but they live
with you
well i don't live there i got two houses
oh so you do have multiple cribs okay
uh
i gotta i said like i got a house where
i just do [ __ ] at parties yeah and then
i got my home where you lay your head
exactly yeah so this is my house not my
home so
i move them all in
um
and just get the drama i guess you know
i'm the host so i just come in and make
them a little bit more maybe competitive
or more
of however they feeling
so
the uh one girl wins each season no
there's no winner there's no winner um
it's just more or less like a if you
make it to the end
you're kind of like tied in type thing
kind of like
you know officially a blue girl and they
get tattoos
it sounds like there's real no incentive
for these girls to come on the show it's
like
you can come
you're gonna leave with a tattoo and
some cloud but really that's about it
well yeah i mean that's what you do with
it you know like
i don't know like they all come for
their own reasons right one might want
to be a rapper
so the exposure for hers
you could you get some
you know you might get a feature or
something yeah
[ __ ] you might meet somebody because we
do studio sessions all the time we go
out you
have these girls never even been to l.a
bro so like i said i'm bringing them
from baltimore florida alabama
jesus that's that that's a pretty good
incentive you get to come to la and what
is what is the
what do you charge per month on the only
fans to watch the show um while i'm
filming it's 50 but like in between time
it's probably like 25 30. so 50 a month
to watch the show like as it's going on
uh-huh
only fans gets their cut i don't even
know what is it what is it 30 no they
just take off 3 percent so if it's 50
they'll take off 10 off each cell and
you get 40.
how many subscribers at one time have
you had like the peak
probably like 2 000 damn that's good
money times 50 950 yeah exactly
yeah
like but but it comes in every month
though yes residual income yeah so you
know because even if someone subscribed
they their intent might be to describe
subscribe for one month they don't
forget to cancel it exactly and it's
only 50 25 50 a month
damn have you thought about [ __ ] on
only fence
you know tiger be on there with his dick
out bruh
that's why i did the blue girls club i
wanted to get only fans but i didn't
want to show my dick yeah
once you show your dick you can't go
back from that yeah it's kind of like
yeah kind of just a porn star at that
point yeah it's like what are we doing
like you know i feel like
if i ever mean but
at the same time as some freaky people
out there who just wanted who actually
would like the thought of somebody
watching them [ __ ] you know yeah i
don't know man who else is [ __ ] on
only fans safari i think safari is
[ __ ] on there tiger's [ __ ] on
there tigers for sure bro i saw his dick
on twitter i mean not even on purpose it
was definitely i didn't seek out listen
i did not seek out tyga's dick just so
we're clear it pops up popped up it
popped up i was like what the [ __ ] just
chilling the tiger's dick just popped up
in your life yes
that's happened before yeah twitter's a
dangerous place yeah
twitter's a dangerous place
on twitter
so that's good that you're not [ __ ]
on there yeah no yeah but
i saw on your ig first of all your ig
just i bro i feel like i've i don't know
how many profiles you've had
i feel like you're kind of like the the
west coast boozy as in terms of ig just
keeps tearing your [ __ ] down they're
trying to
i don't know what it is i don't know hey
i think it's cause facebook just got
with him or something so they kind of
like i'm curious um
no i saw like um i saw on your on your
page like
for i think it was like day 19. there
was a girl in there with two black eyes
yeah
so she got those black eyes like
fighting another girl on the show
um okay so look this is how it works i
insist on them to box so if two girls
have an issue
we do our best to
not
let them get close to each other and
fight
um but we're not watching them 24 hours
you know every minute of the day so
sometimes they might get into a quick
little
right
that could be an accidental win you know
that could be an accidental i just got
the best to you that you know at that
time
so
we break it up and i insist on them to
box because we're not gonna break it up
and you can go as far as you want with
the gloves on you know so that's the
real entertainment part of it that
people love they i i left the box you
have these girls signing waivers right
so you protect yourself
waivers i just want to make sure you're
good waiver god forbid one of these
[ __ ] gets knocked out and hits their
head on the counter or something on the
show and then you're liable
they they sang more than a waiver
[Music]
what's going on with this girl with the
teeth
chris chris shawn rock is that her name
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah i feel like um
you guys have had quite the um
online uh drama
she is she claiming that she's pregnant
by you right now
um
see she's like uh
very like an impulse type of person like
you know she's kind of guy i could tell
yeah she kind of got like real issues
lead to where she she freaks out that's
what she calls it
[Music]
so
she was on the first blue gc
okay but she hung around
um well her tooth fell out during the
show
so wow so yes i i kind of was like okay
well let me make a positive out of this
negative
uh her tooth fell out on the first
season in the first season yeah did she
get punched or something no
um well it goes down at the blue gc
mansion oh you never know we didn't have
helicopters pull up
sheesh but now basically what happened
is my bm was watching the show she got
mad she was feeling some type of way
about
i guess my interaction with them or
their interaction with me
so one night her and her friends all got
drunk and decided to go over there and
confront people oh [ __ ] your baby mama
yes my baby mom
[ __ ] bro i'm like what are you doing
like you're [ __ ] up the back here
man so it's kind of her fault in a way
that
me and kashan even
stood this long together right because
at the end of the day i felt like you
kind of felt bad yeah so i'm like yeah
let me make this negative positive
so boom
as they confronted her she runs
out
you know because it's too many of them
so she runs out of the door but on her
way out she hit her face
on this uh zebra i got in in the living
room
so her tooth was like hanging
so then we took it to the dentist and
they had to pull it
so that's how that's how that happened
it's pretty epic right that just kind of
happens one random day at the bgc i'm
just sitting upstairs talking yeah yeah
so what we're gonna do we're gonna go
places we're gonna see things we're
gonna meet people we're gonna we're
gonna see the world we're gonna you know
we're gonna we're gonna travel yeah yeah
yeah right i'm up there popping it it's
a whole
scope it's a whole [ __ ] wwe royal
rumble literally i'm like damn wow
helicopter came she ran out butt naked
like in the forest
so you kind of felt bad so you're like
you know what keep you around you you
lost the tooth yeah like this and then
obviously i heard a song or two that i
liked yeah so she was like your artist
it's so random because the last time you
guys had drama a few months ago i had
somebody hit me up like hey you got a
plug on that girl i want to get a
feature from her i'm like what yeah yeah
no so
me me turning a negative to a positive
was
signing her and trying to you know make
her an artist right you know because she
had a song or two that i liked
like her music wasn't terrible yeah it
wasn't terrible and she played it for me
like you know like i said i take the
girls to the studio like we do
activities you know it's not like we
just in the house
fighting all day right so let's get that
back so yeah i took her to the studio
heard the music i'm like okay
[ __ ] there's all right let's let's let's
try it get on the song remix one of her
songs give him a song
um shoot videos i got her videos with
real goats
i'm plugging her in she's what right i'm
going out in ross livestream
millions of views off the first day that
she decided she wants to be an artist
all this is happening
so in a way it kind of affected her
hustle
mmm
kind of she kind of got a little lazy
yeah yeah like it affected her hustle
because it was just happening like you
know you know usually when you okay
today i'm gonna be a rapper
you start off with like a thousand views
maybe your first video of course you
just kind of put her straight into the
game she went straight into the millions
so it kind of like
kind of like you know put a little
poison in there in a way
to where she yeah she got real
comfortable real just
just lazy like so are y'all expecting a
child
no bro no you look at the test
i just saw i just saw that you you told
her submit and she said summit and i
think she thought she was using the word
the right way and i was like like
she said yeah i'll sum it
yeah i were to submit you sent her the
definition
literally i said to the screen
like this is what it means like she
thinks i'm trying to like tell her like
i manipulated her like i'm telling her
exactly what i wanted to do like i want
you i got to be like you know walk a
certain way talk a certain way you just
can't be raunchy like right
you know you're going to scare people
you're going to scare the business all
right right right
so i was trying to kind of groom her
but it just
she's
ungroomable she's uncle sorry is that um
relationship professionally personally
severed or is it something that still
could potentially be be patched up
because like you said you might you know
she might have some talent on the music
side like
or is it just too much
it's just too much it's not a
i don't think she really desires to be
an artist you know as much as just up
under you yeah yeah i don't think she
desires to be an artist like she likes
to play football and do all types of
other stuff what the [ __ ] yeah
she likes to play football she blows my
mind
yeah she likes to do a lot of [ __ ] like
football like i got to go to football
practice but what the [ __ ] i'll be like
what league is she is she's a lingerie
league or something she's trying to i
guess you're trying out or whatnot so
that's what her desire lies well she'll
actually get up and be like okay let me
go put some time into this to the today
because i actually want to do this
music she was like one of the last
things she said last thing on her on her
priority list was like you know we'll go
to the studio and you know just um
clear up something because there was a
viral video you you brought up the aidan
ross guy
of you on stream with aidan ross and
your baby mama
[ __ ] wilding out on you because
you're not you missed your kid's
birthday party or you were late or some
[ __ ] what happened that day um
[ __ ] um so
i got one i got a household like i
stayed with my being my son yeah you got
like a family my mom her husband and uh
yo your house is lit yeah like don't
know that's like my real home though
right right my mom's here because she
runs my restaurant yeah
so by the way which is in santa clarita
go tap in yeah restaurants in santa cruz
so she runs my restaurant so that's why
she lives with me right now she lived in
vegas but i'm like
restaurant right here you got to be
right here you know so i moved in
and i love it i love the environment i
go there and i feel like you feel me
like a kid again
but uh
[ __ ]
that matter
i gave you that lighter yeah you gave it
to me
it might be in there
i don't know if you put it down all
right so yeah so that's my environment
so that's the crib yeah so you asked me
about my son's birthday right yeah the
stream [ __ ] so yeah
just so i was just letting you know how
i live so you know if i wake up it's my
son's birthday we all right here right
birthday we'll do a whoo
do this do that so yeah
i was probably there
till
like four o'clock
right then
ddg called me like yo we gotta go
promote this song
this is when moonwalking and calabasas
is on fire yeah yeah yeah you're like yo
this dude livestream is lit i never
heard of 80 months before yeah but he
called me like yo this dude's live
stream is lit pull up
and i'm like all right [ __ ] okay let me
go see what it's about right um so in
the midst of the little you know
birthday shouldn't dig me i had stepped
out for like three hours
and that's so so i think yeah because i
think people
have a misperception that like hey like
you live with your kid you live with
your bm it's not like you were like
absent from the day yeah yeah you
wouldn't handle some business on the day
you know how the internet is
the internet is a wild place man it's
not a place for feelings i'll tell you
that this is do you did because i feel
like you're like one of the earlier
dudes who kind of mastered this internet
[ __ ] for sure um it's not a place for
feelings
do you feel like that like you're you
you you know with tick-tock kind of
evolving the way things are do you still
feel like you're on top of the [ __ ]
uh instagram has definitely affected me
but it's also like made me stronger in
other
positions like are you heavy on tick
tock yeah yeah i got like over 8 million
followers on tick tock jesus christ so
that's how i promote my music right now
like all my shits
so instagram affected me for a minute
but i it just made me like you know just
like cover like yeah you got another
yeah you got to pivot yeah so that's
sort of now
i feel like i'm working my way back up
you know i feel like yeah of course i
went to here
i came down
and then i'm like now i'm like in
between that like you know what i'm
saying let me ask you this because when
you first came out you had a very
interesting situation because your
biggest song at the at the time was
tatiana right you signed this deal with
cash money west universal
but you kept tatiana independent
which would have been a very hard thing
for most people to pull off
most of the time when you
when you make that move onto the major
side they want to take that record with
well yeah see well
what people don't understand is i got
like i'm in the best position as far as
like
our artists could be with like a label
like or like i wasn't asking are you
still on cash money yeah i'm still cash
money west but i'm like the only person
on cash money waste
this is true
so what does that tell you
you're kind of carrying the flag i'm the
only person on this label that means
that they're still gonna have to put
money and you know me i'm still gonna be
doing things like this with you
and
all i really need is just because you'll
have records that come out through e1
so what let me ask you something bro i
have the best dlc
i could do whatever i want listen i'm
being honest like
i i've seen
the shittiest you have one of the best
situations i've seen
i have to tell you and whack
best manager
for the situation because he's
he can muscle [ __ ] like and he got his
he got so many resources because he's
been doing this [ __ ] forever yeah talk
about whack because i think whack is
obviously
more popular than ever
he's um
you know i've known whack for about a
decade now and uh i always tell
everybody you'll wax one of the most
solid [ __ ] you'll ever come
into but what do you think are like some
of the misconceptions about whack
because i feel like there are a lot of
them out there
why why cause 100 like you know
he he will make sure you straight if if
you're in his good graces you know yes
it doesn't take much to being as good
gracious just be a solid like
solid like
well i remember the first time i met you
like him and his wife and they're like
yo we're getting in this house we're
getting this credit together like we're
making sure he got okay i'm in the best
position like you know what i'm saying
like
the music is like half the battle for me
right now like i actually got [ __ ] going
but yeah like back to whack he's one
honey he's a great manager um
his personal life was like you know
that's he should be turned up sometimes
that's that's that clubhouse [ __ ] i'm
like yeah that's what he that's where he
does his
his thing so it's like you know i'm we
don't let that get involved but
did you when you found out that whack
was working with six nine what was your
original reaction
my original reaction i thought it was
kind of weird
i thought it was like you know it made
me look at him
a different way
but not like
not like a
like a [ __ ] you type well it was just
more like oh okay i didn't know you were
that you know
that type of guy
what type of guy like you know just no
just oh you know i don't i don't know
maybe i don't know who i i don't know i
don't even know how how that happened
to be honest with you but
uh you know just like you know like
you're like oh okay that's like okay
yeah like it was one of those like not
like uh oh he yeah [ __ ] he's weird it
was more like a oh [ __ ] right
like not a bad like
like get the money by all by all means
but you know it's just like i think it
threw a lot of people off yeah you know
just kind of like you know it's a big
like
you know
it's definitely uh kind of like uh he's
all he's i know ironic that's very
ironic it's like it's like that collab
of two people that are just like
oh [ __ ]
um
i know he would he was talking forever
about the possibility of you and six
nine boxing
um
how far down the line did those
conversations go
um that might have been
how they they might have maybe been the
angle right yeah that might have been
how they connected because i guess they
might have been in contact trying to
figure out but i never talked to to sign
i wouldn't talk
to him if
he was the last person i had on a jail
call like
you know so i
i guess maybe that's how their
relationship came about
uh as far as the boxing matches got deep
as
him
making like you know
high demands i guess
i think um
yeah the fighting thing is like a whole
nother other way right for you to get a
bag
they paid
good who was it that you fought i saw
the footage i forgot who the [ __ ] it was
though
tick-tock dude mopped them up but they
paid good
would you fight another rapper
i would fight anybody if they paid me
what they baby again [ __ ] i'll fight you
they pay me hey i'll fight you if they
pay me too let's run it hey
you know who you know i want to see i
want to see d smoke fight somebody you
know d smoke is from englewood
he just got nominated for he got
nominated for hip-hop great he won the
netflix show
with the uh dreads yeah
oh yeah okay okay yeah we got to set up
these smoking these these smokes got
hands oh yeah he's got hands yeah i
gotta
get a couple million followers there
might be a little you know we might we
need to talk to what we need to set up
the promotion man
anybody they paying is they paying bro
over over 100
so
you
despite
wax relationship with six and nine you
you draw the line there's no
communication there's no
like you're you're good on that right
as far as just like having any sort of
relationship with homie or even like
let's say like two years from now would
you do a song with six nine
it was just
i mean like i feel like there's no point
at this point like
he's like not like you know not what he
he was so it's like
yeah the the um momentum is definitely
yeah
what would be the point
you could be like he's not
he's not a [ __ ] like that right now you
posted your year wrap up streams i think
it was it was a ton bro but
i feel like that there's like a
narrative that you that you would kind
of acknowledge that you had like like
people say that you have fallen off yeah
yeah
um how do you when you hear that how do
you feel about it
um
i just feel like
i don't think i fell off i think i may
be more stagnated like maybe i'm
where i stopped at
and you know to people that might
be there they might think that's fallen
off
but uh as you can see the streams are
not you know nothing has changed i mean
[ __ ] moonwalking in calabasas is a
platinum yeah yeah no i'm saying and
that song really took off once you got
on i'm still selling platinum records i
know i don't think people understand
like you're still getting plaques
they don't get to see that you feel me
like yeah you don't know they also don't
want to pay attention to that because
yeah yeah like you don't know how much
this song stream for real just did 200
million streams
over and over and over again did you
feel like um there was like a gift in
the curse coming out swinging with like
a number one record like fatian well
that's where i think the falloff thing
comes in it's like people want to see me
on the hot 100. because tatiana was such
a [ __ ] massive
moment yeah it was like it's hard for
anyone to have two of those and i'm not
saying that you won't have another one
but no for sure yeah but yeah it's not
gonna happen
back to back like you know it's gonna
like i got it yeah i got to find my
smooth because that wasn't really my
my angle when i when i came in i had way
more like cripped out songs yes you did
doctoriana kind of like pushed me into
the lane of oh you got to make this type
of music
mm-hmm
like but i got [ __ ] like bleeding and
all
that type of stuff and then i think
daddy went platinum right bro i got i
got somebody platinum i'm already known
even like
i probably got like 10 blacks that's
crazy but
they will never know that because
well they will know one day i'll
flex you know what's crazy i've noticed
over the last couple years the
you being off beat thing when you rap
has like kind of gone away i don't hear
anybody talking about that anymore and i
also want to i've told you this before
but i feel like you've improved
immensely as a rapper and i think when i
heard the one record i heard
was the nle chopper remix you did i
think
and i was like yeah that's platinum too
but i heard that i heard your verse on
there it's platinum too bro and i was
like
yeah this is this is and that's that's
one of my older [ __ ] i feel like i know
that was like two and a half years ago
yeah like now like i'm i'm like a
professional rapper at this point like
yeah like like the way i've been rapping
i'd be surprising myself well i always
think you have like a knack for just
saying like fly funny [ __ ] like lions
are like are like like like dope
one-liners for sure sure yo stop in the
interview got to tell you about our good
folks at odd socks man listen go to odd
socks official.com use the promo code 20
off save 20 off some of the craziest
socks you know i got the ninja turtle
joints
uh shout out to kool-aid you know what
i'm saying shout out to spongebob plus
they got the odd socks basics
these are my boys right here i love
these right here you get the plain black
the plain white very comfortable most
comfortable socks in the world to be
honest you know what i'm saying plus
underwear y'all cheez-it draws
come on what are we doing go to
oddssocksofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg and save 20
off the most comfortable underwear in
the world [ __ ] all that other [ __ ]
y'all be wearing on your ass throw all
the methicas in the trash all that psd
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] is all listen man put
the mod socks on your ass cheeks and
thank me later
how like with everything you have going
on with the show with the restaurants
with fighting
how is music still your number one
priority
[Music]
is it
probably not honestly
like it
like
i don't know i feel like the music is
more like timed out for me
and i'm more on some every day how am i
like you know what can i do today
so
music is more like planned and timed out
so in between them grace periods
it's like probably at the back of my
head right so like this blast record is
going crazy so you're like okay this
record's out i'm gonna do what i got to
do
you know they got this record gotta
go to a certain level for it to you know
go to the next step and then we go to
another record yeah you know so it's
like
what would you say on a day-to-day basis
like as far as just like
what pays you is like your priority like
what do you what do you think you put
the most energy in what i make the most
money no no no just like where you
putting the most energy at daily uh
[Music]
um
kind of it's kind of music like lately
i've been doing a lot of videos with
people i shot a video a fool ago
i saw that yeah it's a wild guy right
there yeah yeah a [ __ ] bro we had him
up here he's he's a nice dude but no
yeah jacksonville dudes are [ __ ] that
[ __ ] is crazy yeah i mean it comes with
the image you know they look like that
like you know that no i just mean the
like the politics in jacksonville oh
yeah are [ __ ] up man oh yeah no no no
no no no it's it's it's uh
it's like the new shirak little key bro
yeah the jacksonville [ __ ] is turnt up
man
i hope like i mean obviously there's
just so much beef going on in
jacksonville it's bad
but now i saw you did the fulio [ __ ]
he's dope nah i [ __ ] about it he's
smooth
um shout out to the video one take today
doing this with you today
how um
like in 2022
say somebody wants to get the feature
and
the video and they want you to be a
prior a primary artist on the record
so they wanted the primary the video the
feature
what's that bag
oh like how much i would
some [ __ ] off the street let's
say the song is just what it's okay it's
not even it's just whatever it's just
like
say some rich dude's son
like yo
blue face i want you to do the record
you got to be primary artist on it on
spotify and you gotta do the video
what's that back
it's not really about the bag like first
i'm gonna i'm gonna control the record
so what if this is established what if
the song is terrible
i'm gonna make it i'm gonna make it
better okay i'm gonna try to do that but
uh like for me to like really take take
it apart and like do it probably i'm
reasonable bro give me like 50. that's
not bad for the primary artist look yeah
and i'm going to promote it i'm going to
promote it like i did mo i'm gonna
promote it like yeah the ddg record was
like yeah like i that's another thing
like i promote my features too so it's
like that's why it does you know make
the difference in
maybe the regular song and
well i think we've seen like records
like that you've hopped on go over the
top like the outside record shout out to
bobby billions shout out to dallas
that record i feel like um
are peter mode three but i feel like
when when you became a part of that
record it kind of really started to take
off in a different way yeah yeah exactly
you know so yeah it took off from like
more mainstream yeah yeah like moe three
was more like his [ __ ] took off more
like like the streets was really filling
up that record when like was that a
record that you you found on your own or
like how did that [ __ ] [ __ ] um
so i like doing the remixes i don't know
if you noticed so i've noticed i got the
that one the outside the milwaukee and
the enderly chopper remix
i don't know i just like the remixes
because i feel like
i am a difference maker on the song
and that's like the best way for me to
like show you without telling you it's
like just to
all right
me make the song a whole new song like
right so
the ddg [ __ ] that [ __ ] uh
how'd that come about we was just
[ __ ]
so i was [ __ ] i would just used to
see bro in it out of the radio station
mm-hmm right this is when daddy is big
and you know i didn't really know who he
was at the time
but i relate that like what's up
so i met him right there i was doing the
high school thing
he hit me
like yo let me pull up with you mm-hmm
so i just [ __ ] with [ __ ] who [ __ ] with
me
he's a good dude too yeah he cool as
hell like we didn't start off doing a
song like you know
so it just came like
he was sending me [ __ ] but i didn't hear
one yet you know
and you know so
then i he had put that one out
i was like
oh trust me trust me i had to i his
manager is a good friend of mine so when
whack posted what whack posted i'm the
one who put them together oh yeah you're
like oh no i know i had to i helped that
make that thing not turn into
yeah whack going on ig say yo som where
the [ __ ] is blue or where the [ __ ] is
ddg
tell i'm like oh [ __ ] i had to hit
dimitri like yo bro yo you gotta just
tap it bro boom and then it worked out
but yeah they just threw that [ __ ] out
there
yeah [ __ ] um so yeah he was sending
me [ __ ] and i just didn't hear the one
yeah and then i heard that one and i was
like yeah ooh remake
quartered it
all right from that day on i promoted it
now you were going hard on that right
here so yeah shout out to bro you guys
are supposed to um do like a like a
mixtape or something right you and yeah
yeah we're doing we're doing our album
bro we got like
10 12 seconds is that's going to happen
oh yeah what's going to happen
it's our has already finished or
yeah we probably got like 10 12 songs
it's just a matter of like just a matter
of us like
getting together you know how hard it is
like yeah two teams two labels two
situations
that's it is like super complicated
super complicated we gotta agree to
disagree to agree how long have you had
that blast record
before it came out
probably like a couple months
being blast just linked up
he's talented man yeah no he's fired
he's fired he's got like he's real like
musically sound he produces his his own
[ __ ]
records himself
he does it all man musically sound
that's that's a musician right there he
is a real musician yeah he's not an
artist he's a musician he does it all
what as far as like is this just a
single are you going to be doing an
album or like what's what's what's next
for you yeah yeah i'm so these singles
i'm driving right now is part of the
project
build up for the album so
you know you're just waiting
yeah what is like um
like like you were saying earlier like
it kind of obviously
the music kind of comes and goes you put
the music out you promote it yeah you
know and then you like you got that
grace period where you gotta
plan for the next play you know
are you like um
you know
how tapped in are you with the new la
[ __ ] that's going on right now because
there's so much
you know just dope [ __ ] going on in the
city right now that obviously is very um
yeah i mean i try to stay typed in but i
don't know i [ __ ] with people who [ __ ]
with me and some people just
come off the wrong way you know and i
don't get a chance to [ __ ] with them so
you know i don't even
i know i know that you and uh
i saw whack post that you and draco had
worked on the record oh yeah yeah we got
one we got one um so i mean i i know
when draco first got out i think a lot
of people had
thought that you were heavily influenced
by his [ __ ]
were you ever like influenced by his
flow and his like kind of his cadence
it's crazy because i feel like i sound
nothing like him like but you but you
have you heard that though no i've heard
it yeah i've heard it but like i feel
like that's like his fans i guess like
you know but like maybe like the lingo
how did you guys end up connecting and
like how how like like what was your
relationship like with draco um well at
first he he came just like i told you he
came off the wrong way
so i wasn't really [ __ ] with him at
first because he was wrong you know he
was like overly like yeah i'm i'm this
i'm daddy
i'm like all right like you know
so at first he just rubbed me the wrong
way so we didn't really get to
click but
when he got out i guess
i don't know if he was more humble or
whatnot but he was just more regular you
know
less like i'm this and i'm that so
um i think he's probably [ __ ] with
whack
brought him to the studio or something
we just did a song
that's hot and that's it yeah like i
could [ __ ] with [ __ ] i just just like
you know i just once you love me the
wrong way it's kind of like i i'm not
i'm not gonna [ __ ] with you until
i have a chance to [ __ ] with you again
which will probably be you're not gonna
go out of your way yeah like it'll
probably happen that happens yeah
so it's like yeah so that's how that
happened but he
he's smooth he just
he's just a little overly
no i know i know i knew i knew draco
yeah exactly rest in peace i'm fully
aware yeah we had him on this podcast he
was tweeting at me like when i first got
cracking he was tweeting at me like oh
blue face this and he ain't seen no
money and i'm like
like
i'm not even not even like
looking at you yeah
like it was kind of like a little like
fake beef like type like it was going in
that direction but i
i'm smooth enough to not even like
well i feel like for the most part
especially you know
i feel like
if you stay out of a lot of rapper drama
yeah i don't do that i don't even do
that that's not even cool you might be
in some other drama
i'd rather be in drama with [ __ ]
yeah that's fair
crap yeah
that's going to be the realest thing
ever i would much rather have drama with
[ __ ] than rappers yeah that's fair
like what that's over player
um do you feel cuz you know obviously
with so much
loss happening within the hip-hop
community especially like
you know in the last year two years do
you do you are you real careful about
how you move around man
you try to stay out the way as much as
possible
i don't know i just just most stay how
how i stay you know that's all i can do
like i feel like you can't prevent
anything from happening you can only
be a little bit more prepared before it
happened because i didn't have people
come to my house so it's like crazy like
how can you what happened there
[ __ ] uh
i guess they came broke a window
um left came back later came in the
broken wood uh you weren't home i wasn't
home but my peoples was there so
my um
mom stepped out i mean my uh my mom's
husband was wrestling with him
they were just trying to rob you or ran
out yeah they were just trying to you
know flock just kid catch up catch a
lick real quick
well i do feel like your cribs are kind
of like you're on instagram a lot like i
mean i feel like any famous person i
could find their house
yeah
can you google kanye's address i don't
know he says he doesn't have an address
now he says his address is his backpack
so i don't know what that means but
that's i'm just saying telling you what
he said
okay you think they can google jay-z's
address probably beyonce yeah
i mean look if you go we're in hollywood
you could literally jump on a tmz tour
bus and they'll drive you past famous
people this is blue face's house right
so it's so dangerous it's like by the
way there's like nothing you can really
do about it you could just be prepared
yeah
be prepared
what was your uh
inspiration for opening the restaurant
man talk about the restaurant because uh
you know i i think it's dope i love to
see artists getting getting getting into
businesses and opening businesses that's
like my favorite thing there probably
about that about myself that i like is
that i went in that direction too um
i was [ __ ] soul food spot yeah yeah
i was i just walked in there i was
buying a car and i was hungry and it was
open so i walked in there
like yo i'm selling it
tired of it i'm over there they were
selling the business yeah they were
selling the the space right
so i was like uh
all right [ __ ]
so some quick [ __ ] like what is for
people who don't know because like
obviously it's a smaller restaurant what
does a restaurant like that go for
uh
i paid 80. that's not bad 80 bands and
you got all the equipment it felt bad
[ __ ]
yeah i had already yeah that's what that
came with all that stuff that was the
coolest thing though that was the
coolest yeah that's not bad that's not
bad i felt like it was just kind of high
like
80 you get all the equipment you get the
lease you get the space
i'm thinking how much do you think that
would cost to do without by yourself i
don't know
how much all that equipment is that you
got so i don't know what you bought no
i'm saying but if if i leased out a
place
an old
restaurant it just depends because you
bought you own all that [ __ ] now so it
just depends like oh okay i didn't even
think about it like you bought all the
you bought i own friars and [ __ ] yeah so
i could take it out of that place if i
ever leave yeah oh okay
yeah 80's not bad
i mean unless unless you don't own all
that [ __ ]
well i do but i didn't think that far i
thought you know
yeah i think if you think about that
right if you buy all that stuff so i own
stoves and greasers and [ __ ] i mean
for him your [ __ ] names on the
building
hell yeah okay
thanks for the game clear no but like
how is because the restaurant game is
tough man
it's hard actually it is it's up and
down so the holiday season was like
right you know it's colder it's raining
well dope is probably like a destination
for some of your fans who come into town
they're like yo we could go pull up on
blue faces
yeah so that's what's really making the
difference for my restaurant and maybe
the average person is just
you know i just gotta i'm you know we
have a platform
we got we got them in five stars right
now man on yelp
nice
that's fire give me something hey
yeah
so so did you come up with the menu your
mom comes up with the menu my mom is i
let her do her thing
i'm not even the type of person to
micromanage just let mom handle it yeah
like
so that's another thing you know i got
to make my mom a boss and let her
you know hire people fire people
that's dope man yeah yeah that's and and
it's also kind of out the way too so
like you ain't got no like if i hate it
if a hater really wants to [ __ ] with
your restaurant in my hood so i'm saying
if a hater wanted to [ __ ] with your
restaurant they got to take a little
drive yeah like you got to come and
actually
[ __ ] up a few chances drive past the
place be on camera get you're going to
get caught that way yeah that's
beautiful man yeah it's not i plan on
moving one probably closer to my area
but like i'm i want to get the structure
down first get the restaurant down yeah
i got to get there open another one open
the second location that's that's what
i'm saying that's where i'm really
trying to go like are y'all on postmates
and [ __ ] yeah we
100 oh that's fire yeah
we square we doing square business man
yo take me back to your college days you
were playing quarterback in college
right yeah yeah what school you were in
fayetteville yeah so you were in where
cole's from and um the homie moray's
from there oh yeah yeah i was out there
for like two months so
you had a short-lived
college football career though yeah
people don't realize that i remember the
first time i met you
you came up and freestyled on our show
and like i had like whatever thoughts i
had just based on seeing you on the
internet yeah and i always told
everybody after that i was like yeah
this dude's got a [ __ ] great head on
their shoulders like a very bright
individual yeah um but like what what
was
what was your journey like as like a a
college athlete man how was that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] was cool i was i wasn't doing
the school though so so that that's why
it didn't last yeah it was like uh
probably this is not for me like i was i
was trying to get up out of there before
this
report cards even came out because i
wouldn't even been able to you feel me
well playing quarterbacks like the
hardest position in all of sports they
say for sure because you got to know all
the plays
you got to you got to lead everybody on
the is that you played quarterback in
high school yeah yeah so that's kind of
what's moted me to be able to lead you
know
today so lead a whole house of [ __ ]
you lead a football team a whole house
of [ __ ] you feel me whole house
family
and then you can give the chick with no
teeth pointers on her football practice
are you looking to sign other artists
because you signed her uh or no hell no
hell no
that was that was an accident you know i
wasn't looking for artists when i signed
her i was just trying to be a nice guy
that's over
yeah i mean it kind of like backfired so
kind of like was more reassurance of why
i didn't
that's fair if i was ever curious like
oh should i
bring somebody on [ __ ] though have you
had any uh tv networks try to get at you
to try to bring the tv show to like
their network
no
i mean not directly right
i doubt
zeus would know how to call blueface you
know what i'm saying so no not directly
but i haven't even i haven't even been
looking in that direction like
i only did this so i could get on only
fans um
without showing your [ __ ] exactly yeah i
was showing my dick i wasn't trying to
be on tv that's fair i'm like i want to
i need to get i need some of that only
fans of mine i need to you know events
somehow like
that's like having your own netflix you
filming your own netflix profile and you
can just upload your movies
and see the streams are we in the middle
of a season right now
nah uh um
no i just finished the season so i'm on
season three season four now but you're
looking for season four i just saw you
post you're looking for women pgc bgc
yeah yep i'll be doing that
i'm still doing it so
i should tell you it's not do you feel
like there's any uh do you feel like you
might be taking advantage of these girls
a little bit
i think they're taking advantage of me
honestly
what the [ __ ]
because you gotta understand these women
are already
trying to
maybe chase a dream or pursue something
or
you know so it's like
it's like picture me as an artist
and somebody gave me the position a
platform to even just
be seen
if that's what i need for whatever my
dream is
i don't need no money for that
for sure i don't need no money because
i had to pay money when i started
rapping you got to pay
to go to the studio you got to pay the
photo video man so it's like you know
it's a different type of
hustle i guess for me than what they
come from i don't think they come like
oh i'm just trying to
i just need a platform to
up where i'm you know what i got going
on
have you noticed like most of these
[ __ ] just are there to try to [ __ ]
you
yeah yeah i've noticed that actually you
know after doing three seasons i've
noticed that it's kind of becoming weird
like it's not really about
them chasing their dreams it's what i've
actually started about it's more about
them trying to hook up with who's
[ __ ] and who's boxing and who's
and who's on the internet and it's like
yeah is your baby mama pretty lenient
it's terms of just like letting you get
your [ __ ] off on the side
uh
you just asked that's a question so
weird hold on let me think about a good
answer
he just threw me way off with that [ __ ]
i mean this is your baby mama you're
around a bunch of women okay with you
[ __ ] everything right what all right
wait um
my baby mama
we are
like i said we live together i got like
a cool understanding yeah like you know
yeah
like
i got a real like
household like you know so it's like you
got to keep that
keep that that's you know priority not
for sure yeah like you know like where
where what better place could you be
i forgot what as far as her
position for sure
there was an artist that just came out
[ __ ] it might have been you and i forget
but there was an artist that just came
out and said that they had a 16 some
who was that
we just talked about it on the radio
show [ __ ] i forgot that's an orgy bro
that's not a 16 song someone said they
had a 16 son
what has been your your number all at
once
since since this newfound fame
four a four so so so five people all
together you're with four women yeah
what is the uh like
the girls working on each other you're
working like what like like break down
what happens it's actually very hard
like you have to be a leader
to do it you are a quarterback you have
to you feel me audible audible bend over
turn around eat harass yeah like you
gotta like know how to because you don't
the worst thing that could happen
is
one girl doing something everybody's
just looking like
they're just staring yeah like it's just
it's awkward like yeah you can't let
that happen whenever you doing like
multiple girls at the same time you can
never like you got to make sure
everyone's busy every year like you're
all right you see in your mouth right
now yeah yeah okay yeah oh bob yeah oh
school yeah i gotta you feel me scissors
scissors
yeah so
but that was a while ago that i was like
when i was first coming in
it just happened on accident they were
like oh they were like
is that even fun having four at once it
seems like a lot of work no it was it
was not it was not fun that's something
that that was something that you would
make a porn for because you're actually
working yeah it feels like it feels like
you you're not you're worried about four
different women's feelings all at once
and making sure everyone's having
gotta have a lot of dick for that like
you gotta have the dick like maybe once
licking the toes like a dr dre's or what
was it one riding dick one licking my
toes i don't know what was that song off
the chronic 2001 that was was that
corrupt
you're not
gonna have a lot of dick for that a lot
of dick for four girls
yeah
for them to be you know even oh get
[ __ ] you gotta
you like line them up it's like
um
did i line them up no i was more
directive like i might have been getting
some hair like are you
uh uh
you either [ __ ] while she giving me
head and you know boom or i might have
two heads on there and they both eat
them the twofer the two first so maybe
you have two sucking your dick while the
other ones are behind each of them
eating them running the play you feel me
down saying
it's kind of like human centipede top of
the pyramid
you're at the top of the pyramid
i only did that one time no five
something like that that's a fivesome
that might be an orgy
if it passed three is it is it an orgy
it was it was hard though like it's not
something i deserve i'm sure it was hard
it's not something i desired it was hard
yeah it was
i wish you were there you could have
helped out i'm good man have you ever
done that like done like the the the the
having a homie like you guys passing
hoses
i had one situation y'all not real
homies to tell y'all you feel me i did
have a situation and it was um
it was very awkward because i my homie
had really big balls
and i was like bro
the [ __ ] is like i i couldn't like i i i
i had to tag my way out because i was
like
yeah i ain't in this [ __ ] you gotta like
you can't do it like that like y'all
can't both have y'all dicks out and her
head just
sucking trying to say you can't do it
like that no it's like one on the end
yeah you got to be on both ends you got
it right so this is something you've
done it's just like a few times
so for you someone's not an actual homie
until you guys [ __ ] a [ __ ] together is
that what you're saying
no not actual homie we just
a little closer you know
just a little it's just another type of
bond well what are the rules well what
are the rules there right because you
don't want to cross swords
that's why i'm saying you got to be at
several days
and then and then you switch yeah
rotate you can't don't don't i don't
even rotate on the same side of her you
go around this side of where i go around
this side yeah you guys can't even pass
each other yeah yeah yeah you don't want
to pass your boy with both dicks out
that's weird because then you're gonna
see his balls so you probably i was
probably getting head together no no no
no no no i just happened to take oh
[ __ ] i can't even see it i'm out i can't
see it i'm gone i'm i'm checking out man
um no that's that's like the old me i
don't even do that type of [ __ ] no more
this is what we've seen
now you're calm down
yeah like now
i'm cool with like one i'd rather just
take care of the fam take care of the
household one at a time um
and the other girl's not pregnant with
your baby right
hell no she's she's full of [ __ ] she's
not even pregnant she's not pregnant
she only posted that because i i took a
picture with somebody else oh so it was
it was one of those yeah like i told you
she freaks out and do the impulse and
her first
thought in her head to just destroy
something is what she's gonna
yeah angle i saw when i first because i
after i'm not hip to what's going on in
your house i'm not a subscriber oh yeah
it's going down
so i just remember see like whatever
happened between y'all a few months ago
i remember just seeing this girl with no
teeth and i was like yo blueface is a
good looking guy and this [ __ ] has no
teeth i don't understand like am i
missing something here like yeah
yeah you know
i think she looks fine
i think she's still pretty with one
tooth
also i don't think it's affecting her
like
the average person will be like oh my
god does it affect the oral though like
does it make like is there like a is
there like a jagged like a jagged tooth
there like i don't know
no no it doesn't
doesn't affect it
yo what is um
you know obviously it's a new year man
uh we're gonna get an album this year
you can get two albums two albums maybe
the ddg project that's one of the two
any more fights
i hope so
that's it if they pan that
i think the six nine blueface fades
gotta be that's gotta be the one yeah
and then whack is the reference
like the referees like vince mcmahon
coming in like
special guest referee whack one huh
right with the shirt and everything now
i kind of gave up on that idea he's not
gonna
he doesn't not wanna participate in that
time if you could fight any other rapper
who would it be
[Music]
for everyone who can hear that in the
background that's whack 100 yeah 100 on
the phone right now
on a regular tuesday um nah
i don't know anybody my size i don't
want to get more of a
reaction um
because the other guy was like smaller
than you right
you know boxing by weight so it's not
really well you had you got that reach
though yeah you know so it's probably
gonna be it would be hard to find
somebody my size you know did you like
really train because i you i saw the
video you training but yeah you really
committed to that [ __ ] i was training uh
for probably i probably needed to train
more but i was training for like how
long they gave me they gave me like two
months
so i mean it worked for two months like
an hour a day that's
not enough
i mean you're like an athlete too so
it's kind of yeah i was after that fight
i was were you gasping i was in the back
looking like i lost the fight because
she was gassed right i'm like
i don't think people understand like
yeah they just want to give you an id i
was gonna throw up
i don't think people understand that
fighting [ __ ] is like when you see
someone go like 12 rounds you're like i
don't know how they do it that shit's
insane yeah so it's definitely i respect
the
hustle a lot more
like you need that sport takes you top
your head to the bottom of your feet
yeah cause like i think it's kind of a
new thing now like every this celebrity
boxing [ __ ] just kind of brought like uh
jesus christ whacking on his [ __ ] he get
on his [ __ ]
um i just feel like it's like a whole
new you know my son's interested in
boxing out he never gave a [ __ ] about
boxing yeah no it's definitely bringing
a lot more attention to the sport so the
people that are coming and those
undercards are like real fights like you
know when jake paul fights the
undercards are real fights they're
getting a shot to be seen and you know
make their legacy so
i don't know you know of course the the
the boxers are
going to bash it you know well listen
two albums this year
the new blast single is out
uh
anything else man the restaurants in
santa clarita yeah another restaurant
this year another restaurant this year
anything else you want i mean obviously
only fan what's the only fans
well yeah i already did that four times
so to go to go subscribe yeah go pay
fifty dollars
uh
there's a [ __ ] on there with two black
eyes
shout out to her she's i'm still
prettier than you [ __ ] and i got two
black eyes
i said oh [ __ ] yeah they they sandwiches
man they they tough uh maybe a fight
this year
maybe we'll see man well look i
appreciate your time fam
blue face